Il y a 100 ans après la guerre, nos fondateurs ont
créé un système qui, selon eux,
créerait une paix durable, ils ont divisé la
société en cinq factions, la seule façon
de survivre est que chacun de
vous revendique sa place légitime,
tout le monde est testé pour déterminer qui nous
sommes et où nous  appartenez
dites au revoir vos familles êtes-vous
nerveux Non
je suis terrifié prêt
vos résultats n'étaient pas concluants
c'est impossible n'est pas impossible c'est
juste extrêmement rare vous êtes capable de
contrôler et de vaincre vos peurs ils appellent
ça divergent vous n'entrez pas dans une
catégorie ils  vous ne pouvez pas vous contrôler
vous ne pouvez faire confiance à personne vous devez vous cacher
dans une faction pour survivre
bienvenue au bureau et c'est nous
allons regarder pour voir qui vous êtes vraiment
vous voulez dire une erreur en choisissant
intrépide ils découvriront sur vous  Je
sais ce que tu es tu as peur des
hauteurs tout le monde a peur de quelque chose
mais pas ta peur ne t'arrête pas
et ne te réveille pas c'est ce qui te rend
dangereux les
divergents menacent le système il a gagné  je ne
serais pas en sécurité jusqu'à ce qu'ils soient enlevés elle
va me tuer
nous devons être prêts à tout ce que le
monde change tu dois décider à qui
tu es fidèle
toute ma vie j'ai vécu selon tes
règles plus
toi